one fine morning your distant aunt carol
came to your family home in an almost
frantic state of excitement
carol had always been a bit eccentric
totally harmless of course
but what you'd describe as being on the
more zealous side of religious
predictably she wanted to ask you and
your family to come to church with her
seeing as you don't see on carol often
you and your family decide that there's
no harm in indulging her
you're not an atheist family by any
means in fact you were all raised
catholic
but it felt like it'd been forever since
you last went to church
aunt carol wanted to show you and your
family the special celebrations that
went on at her church
you remember her practically grabbing
you by the wrist and dragging you to the
building
her eyes filled with a crazed enthusiasm
that's when you saw something incredibly
strange
there were shadows moving behind the
elaborate stained glass windows
thousands of tiny shadows darting around
and this low humming noise you faintly
recognized
what was that noise it was the cry of
cicadas
but this was only early spring what were
cicadas doing awake at this time of year
you didn't get much time to ponder this
question in the next few seconds
you and the entire church were
surrounded by heavy-duty tactical
vehicles
what appeared to be a large and heavily
armed swat team poured out of the
vehicles
unbeknownst to you these were a mobile
task force sent in by the scp foundation
specifically mtf y99 also known as the
altar boys
a specially trained group of foundation
agents used for anomalies of a religious
nature
you your aunt and the rest of your
family are rounded up to be debriefed
and given amnesics
one of the last memories they took from
you was the sight of foundation agents
dragging bloody bodies out of the church
as the doors opened thousands of cicadas
streamed out and disappeared into the
skies
but these weren't like any kind of
cicada you'd ever seen
they were beautiful the rainbow colored
wings reminded you
of ornate stained glass who could have
guessed that these pretty little bugs
are tied to an entity
very likely to bring about an xk class
end of the world scenario some day in
the future
the bugs the bodies in the church and
even your aunt's incredibly strange
behavior
all fall underneath the umbrella of a
ketter class anomaly known as
scp scp-3004 but to truly understand
this anomaly
that was once thought to be destroyed
and the implications of it still living
today
we need to go back 600 years to ireland
in the 15th century this era was
believed to be the origin of a gaelic
religious movement
known as ketlaji or the singers in
english
a splinter sect of druidism but this was
no fringe cult
the singers were a mainstream religion
in the british isles for several hundred
years
its members included people of all
social classes from lowly peasants to
powerful and respected figures
they mingled heavily with christians
mostly irish catholics and at some point
in history came close to overtaking
christianity as the dominant religion in
ireland
so who were these people if there's
supposedly such a large part of recent
history in the area
like most druids their relationship with
nature was a key part of their belief
system
in particular they prized an extinct
species of cicada known as cicada
luculenta or the stained glass cicada
in english the life cycle of birth and
resurrection that the cicadas underwent
fascinated the singers and they
performed a number of holy rituals
around it
one recorded ritual was the celebration
of children entering adulthood
that was marked by them first losing
their baby teeth but the rituals of the
singers accidentally opened some kind of
door to a being from a different plane
of reality
dubbed scp-3004-1 by the foundation
this being is an immensely powerful
thought form that the foundation
believes to be a pitus phage
or faith eater it appears to have been
attracted to our universe by the rituals
of the singers
and so took a form relevant to their
beliefs
namely a huge cicada in order to feed on
their faith
if things had stopped there then this
would be an almost innocent symbiotic
relationship
but the interactions between scp-3004-1
and our world led to dangerous
consequences
due to its powerful reality warping
abilities for example
during some rituals huge numbers of
stained glass cicadas would burst
from the mouths of those participating
often causing them to choke to death
other times 3004-1 would manifest
physically in the sky above its new
worshipers
causing painful boils on whoever
witnessed it and occasionally symptoms
akin to radiation sickness
it appeared that 3004-1 was growing more
powerful over time
and its rise to power was intrinsically
linked to the rituals of the singers
and the existence of the stained glass
cicadas
two groups that predated the foundation
the vatican's congregation for
otherworldly acts
and the english government's royal
society for the imprisonment of
abnormality
essentially performed an all-out
religious genocide on the singers
no meaningful trace of the religion was
left when they were done
aside from their own records while they
were at it they also exterminated
all the stained glass cicadas leading to
a complete stop of all
scp-3004 activity it seemed like despite
the great human
and ecological cost the anomaly had been
neutralized
a few centuries later though a series of
strange cicada-related anomalous events
started to occur
across the united states a strange man
seemingly made almost entirely from
cicada kaiten
would appear at christenings weddings
and funerals
each time his presence would cause the
people in attendance to do
and experience horrific things and lead
to legacies of hardship and death that
would linger for decades
this became known as scp-2852
or cousin johnny and it should have been
the first clue that the nightmare of
scp-3004 was resurfacing
but since 3004 was already archived as
neutralized
nobody made the connection some time
later
scp-2852 incidents ceased and around
that exact time
scp-3004 instances started anew
it manifested in the form of strange
anomalous activities taking place at
christian church services specifically
those from roman catholic
eastern catholic anglican and
episcopalian communities the only clues
to outsiders would be an
increase in reported church attendance
and an increase in deaths from natural
causes within the community
these two stats were how the foundation
first noticed something
was amiss just as it had done with the
singers centuries before
scp-3004-1 had latched onto the beliefs
and rituals of christians
and was using this new connection to
harvest more faith for sustenance
the results were twofold first religious
fever and excitement to attend church
services saw
a huge increase secondly the actual
content of these services took a hard
turn for the horrific
much like cousin johnny infiltrations
this really isn't for the faint of heart
by any definition
for example young people with
christ-like stigmata wounds being bitten
to death by priests
children removing the teeth of priests
before they all start vomiting huge
numbers of stained glass cicadas
there were extremely unpleasant rituals
involving castration
and even a pregnant woman giving birth
to even more swarms of stained glass
cicadas
we could go on but you probably get the
idea
rituals inspired by scp-3004-1 are
horrific
and all seem to involve the same extinct
breed of stained glass cicadas
worshiped by the singers before their
annihilation
but how can these insects which have
been dubbed scp-3004-2
be here in the present if the foundation
forerunners made them extinct
so many centuries ago the answer is
simple
but strange well they have all the
hallmarks of being alive
the stained glass cicadas present during
modern iterations of scp-3004 events
aren't actually real genetic tests have
shown that they're actually made from a
mix of wood and real stained glass
these insects fly away from the scene
after the rituals are completed
traveling around 600 miles from the site
before disappearing completely
the foundation was growing concerned
about the nature of scp-3004
especially given that instances were
becoming more frequent and harder to
contain
foundation scientists determined that
the creature known as 3004-1
likely existed within a layer of reality
just above
our own and if it ever managed to breach
our reality
the world level of violence and chaos it
could cause would likely lead to an
xk-class end of the world scenario
drastic actions would once again be
needed to prevent this
so they devised an emergency containment
procedure that would only be used as a
last resort
the procedure known as protocol damantio
albestias
would use a mixture of mass amnestic
treatment and thalmial objects to
completely erase
christianity from not only the modern
world
but all of history in hopes of cutting
off scp-3004-1's food supply
to kill the entity or at least prevent
it from entering
our world the plan would center on
placing a powerful roman catholic
reality warper who volunteered for the
job of course
into an anomalous group of machines
known as the lions
by submitting the reality warper to a
lifetime of suffering and essentially
erasing him from existence
so too will it erase the world's full
knowledge of christianity
and hopefully save the world this man
will become the last martyr
dying for all of humanity he will become
the last
saint saint jude the damned bulwark
against darkness
you might ask are you sure that's
necessary there's so much we don't know
about 3004-1
do we know for a fact that it's
dangerous enter agent timothy letterman
a member of mobile task force sigma 25
also known as
ghostbusters letterman was part of a
foundation project known as
sightsee lux using an astral projection
technology that would free his
consciousness
from his body and allow it to travel
freely between metaphysical planes
in plain english they could use
letterman's floating mind as a kind of
spy
and insert it into 3004-1's dimension
they achieved this by capturing one of
3004-1's false stained glass cicadas
and releasing it again allowing
letterman's mind to follow at home
to its master however what we thought
would be a simple intel gathering
mission turned into a complete nightmare
letterman found that 3004-1's dimension
was entirely void
aside from the entity itself and the
millions of buzzing stained glass
cicadas
the entity was so huge and so complex
that it physically hurt to look at
letterman observed that its form kept
shifting from a giant cicada
to an old man to a cicada nailed to a
wooden cross
to an infinite mess of wood and stained
glass
but even more terrifying than its
physical appearance were the contents of
its
mind 3004-1 forced itself into agent
letterman's brain
and in that moment he finally understood
it
the entity which had no concept of
metaphors allegory or the divide between
fact and fiction truly believe that it
was the abrahamic god depicted in the
bible
and that all christians are lovingly
worshiping it in its rituals
it was imposing some of the bloodiest
parts of the bible onto its flock
believing that's what they wanted all
the while it fed on their faith
growing bigger and more powerful
letterman found that just being there
with the creature was hurting his soul
if it wasn't a god yet he believed it
had the power to become one in time
and he advised the foundation shouldn't
send anyone else to its dimension
it was too great a risk to all life on
earth
perhaps to prevent the horrible fate of
all of us being destroyed by 3004-1
erasing christianity would be a worthy
sacrifice
that is if it actually works after all
they thought destroying the singers
would neutralize 3004 once and for all
and yet here it is again for all we know
we may just be prolonging the inevitable
now go check out scp-001 the children
orborus cycle
and scp-5000y the full compilation for
more freaky anomalies with world
shattering implications